christoph christina ich bin aber dran
und mich als österreicher deutschen
hybriden würde es mich mal interessieren
was ist christina deiner meinung nach
der größte unterschied zwischen
österreichern und deutschen
danke für die antwort der größte
unterschied zwischen den deutschen und
österreicher das sehr sehr schwer zu
sagen weil in österreich sondern
österreicher manchmal so verschieden
sein können und da deutsch und dadurch
auch vor allem an bayer und
norddeutscher das sind ja zwei
verschiedene paar schuhe und ein tiroler
und ein wiener das sind auch zwei
komplett verschiedene paar schuhe was
ich aber mehr oder weniger was von den
live konzerten sagen kann ist dass ein
österreicher bisschen länger braucht
finde ich dass er mit geht ich weiß das
klingt vielleicht gemein oder was aber
ich bin ja selber österreichern kann das
von mir auch behaupten ich gehe zwar im
konzert und brauche einfach ein bisschen
länger dass sich warm werde weil ich vor
überzeugt werden möchte ich bin halt
eher so kopf bitten und fuß und braucht
dann auch zwei drei songs dass ich
vollgas dabei bin und der deutsches
manchmal wenn ich jetzt wirklich alle in
einen topf werfen müsste dann ist das
schneller da ganz einfach an was auch
immer das liegt